there are very few people who've ever
reached your level of fame and
i'm talking biblical status that's like
moses
mike tyson michael jordan
you know i mean that level it's like man
dude you go to remote parts of africa
they're like fights i said
they said i'm sorry they don't look at
me like
white chicks
remember man we used to sit and watch
eddie murphy eddie murphy raw
he would be saying you know the f word
and
yeah you know what i mean and man we
were laughing and then you look back and
now you go oh man
you know how many people that hurt you
know how many people you know they're
stuff man you look at all these 80s
comedies
and man you cringe man because everybody
anybody black anybody female
you're a joke you're not even a real
human
a lot of stuff i laughed at when i was
young i go oh man
yeah so many movies oh you're like they
wouldn't even be able to make that now
tell me what happened what's the girl
name and then um
the mexican girl tell me oh with gina
rodriguez what's the deal with that one
well some gina had made some comments
that
that black women have felt were
anti-black you know and she
she literally was like yeah but you know
what about hispanics and when black
women were saying things she would jump
in and be like but what about
you know the latino community and
everybody and black women were like wait
a minute just let us get our word out
and people and then she said she had a
dark dad and her father wasn't dark
and he was really like you know regular
and and they felt like she was pandering
and i know gina i know gina i work with
her
and i felt like wow you know i know this
girl we talk about this stuff she's cool
but i backed her up and then being the
black women were like hell no don't you
do that and i said you know and i
realized
there i was as a man trying to hold a
woman accountable
that wasn't my place i had to back up i
had to back up
went listen black women didn't like it
who am i to say
you know what i mean i was like listen i
ain't a black woman so i had to step
back
so what do you think um tell me this
this is interesting we're talking about
black women
do you think the black women think that
all black men or you particularly
should be there um shiny night uh
technium i do they think first of all
black women are the ones that back me up
yeah they're the only ones that back me
when i when i told my story
man negroes was like man get the [ __ ]
out of here
you look how big you are man you should
just bad you should smack his ass
they say you must be gay you must have
wanted it that's what d.l usually said
the ugly was like well look man god gave
your muscles so you can say no
and i was like wait but black women was
like nah [ __ ]
no cause i know these because
you know the rapists in your
neighborhood you know the molester in
your neighborhood look i remember being
in school
and i was 13 and there was growing ass
men at the school
and it was like i said there was only my
classmates and i said hey man
ain't you 35 and they were like hey
man hey what's up with that little girl
man i just know you're like huh
if you're a big black [ __ ] you
start putting your hands on these
[ __ ] white like people in
hollywood
they're gonna get it's gonna get tricky
okay
it's gonna be really tricky i think it's
really really tricky but what
but black women however see this is the
thing too
and i'm gonna say this i'm gonna keep
saying it hey man
i i could talk about i could talk about
my community because i'm a black man
go for it i'm gonna talk about what i
see but we good at rapping
we're excellent rappers oh we can wrap
somebody under the table but action
is a different deal and what black women
have been demanding from black men
forever is
action hey man i remember waiting on my
great gran my on my
uh grandfather waiting on him he said he
gonna pick me up he never show up
yes i mean you do that few times to a
black woman they're like hey
you know some of these [ __ ] ain't
doing nothing go ahead
what do you think about uh the
kaepernick deal
oh off first of all now let's go back to
the nfl nfl wanted me
they actually the commissioner invited
me to be a part of some domestic
violence council sexual assault thing
and i wouldn't go
cause i knew they wanted it to be a a
press conference
and i said so y'all want to use me as oh
wow look terry's here excellent
we're doing something about it i was
like but y'all still
i said every day kaepernick does not
play delegitimizes the league
you can't tell me he's not in the top 30
quarterbacks in the world
like what a joke it's how are you
ignoring this
how can you even feel and listen you
know what it's like hey look the academy
awards are coming up it's like having
the best movie out there or at least
let's say
one of the tops and we totally ignoring
it and everybody just says oh no but
there ain't no black panther what
black panther movie i've never heard of
black panther you understand what i'm
saying and that kind of stuff
when you when you had all those awards
and stuff those oscars
listen i used to be listen to this [ __ ]
man this is why i used to go to those
awards before i [ __ ]
you know act like a [ __ ] animal
hitting on people and [ __ ] i used to go
what this was the [ __ ] best time for
my life yeah i want to see
all your friends and stuff yeah hanging
out with your friends good partners it
feels like
a great part of going back with your
friends well it feels like you're
working stuff
and we all know each other it feels like
a reunion don't you think in the nfl the
players
need to [ __ ] start standing up for
themselves and
that's the only way they're gonna have
any kind of shift
you know in power they're making
kaepernick the example
um it's almost like me too i would never
tell a woman
that you have to go public like you
don't pressure people
into like now look tell your story yeah
uh
stand out like like even when even when
people
doing this whole thing i didn't go at
any actors in hollywood for not
doing or whatever i understand what the
controversy is they're like okay it's
disrespectful
to kneel during the national anthem or
whatever because it's it's they feel
like it's disrespectful
i don't agree but but this is the point
that's the point everybody's making
but why are you selling beer during the
national anthem
why are the concessions still open
during the national anthem
why can't i go walk over and buy a flag
and go buy a t-shirt during the national
anthem
all employees of the nfl have to stop
and stand during the national anthem
i had a lawyer tell me he was like damn
i never thought about it like that
that's like having a building where only
the second floor has to stand for the
national anthem and everybody else can
continue working
not right dude because what happens is
you look like you're just pinpointing
these guys
and ever let me tell you they want to
play they want to play the game ain't
nothing wrong with the game
nothing wrong with football it's but all
the attitudes that come around it
it's garbage man garbage
i was acting like i was on drugs never
getting high i was drinking though but
the [ __ ] i was doing is stupid someone
was looking at me weird what the [ __ ]
happened
you gotta i remember my i remember i
didn't i didn't go up to you but
this is back in 91. i was a rookie
but you came to practice i remember you
came ram park the whole thing
everybody was flipping i was in awe i
was
in awe that's so cool
see but you gotta understand i mean
literally
you were the ex i mean still are the
example of what manhood is
it's really tough to you know have a
family too
you gotta be able to laugh man you're
[ __ ] you know it's all about that
husband and i mean do be in a
relationship with people man
there are probably 10 guys i played with
i'm 50
all died before 45. 10.
hey i played with junior seau man one of
the best
linebackers let's do it and he's all the
same he dude
it's depressing it's heartbreaking and
the league has not
acknowledged that these guys need help
because the thing is they
they need you slightly messed up yeah
they need
you needing them yeah yeah like you
can't be all together you can be a
quarterback
and be all together but everybody else
you want to play with that kind of pain
you got to be damaged
yeah coming out of it i th you know
looking back
as a rookie everything is about
protect the shield you're privileged to
be here
you know this is about us you know
anytime you do anything
we're gonna turn your back turn our back
on you yeah you know
but think about this they've been using
you since college yeah
wait if you got an ncaa scholarship
you've been you've been extorted all the
way you
dude that's exploitation yeah how in the
world these cats gonna make billions of
dollars off this free
these guys are playing for free mike for
free
yeah free labor that's free labor how
about some health insurance
can we get lifetime health insurance all
you got to do
just imagine if they give if they gave
these guys 25 000 a year and told them
if they graduate you get 100 grand at
the end
so you can start your life that's that's
all doable
oh yeah that's way doable so doable but
the 14 billion dollar industry listen
man you know what they told me i i quit
i had to go i got dropped in the nfl
in the 11th round by the rams they told
me
and i said and i had 12 credits left i
only have 12 i still don't have
to college for college i still they you
know what they told me they said hey man
you got
you got to you got to come back and pay
you got to pay
to go back i was like y'all can't just
health insurance no
yeah hey man you blow your knee out in
college your knee's still blown out oh
yeah you're [ __ ]
i mean you're yeah so terry tell me this
um when it was all over and football was
over when everything was over and it was
just boom
everything's all that [ __ ] did you say
what the [ __ ] am i gonna do
i was depressed what did you do how did
you like how did it work you know what
and that's happening
what the [ __ ] happened let me tell you
what happened it's my money where's my
friends where's my shirt oh i was alone
first of all first of all i had man look
i was sitting in
i remember my wife and i were it's a
really bad
feeling man where everybody went i
gained oh
[ __ ] 30 pounds i gained very vulnerable
yeah oh
vulnerable you are like a baby
you can't get a loss you can't get a
mile close to me now nobody's around so
i get welcome and smack the [ __ ] out of
you
i wasn't nowhere on your field like no i
wasn't like this yeah no i mean nobody
even knew me you know by that time
you know if you got the helmet on nobody
know what they even know you look like
you know what
but i mean i was nowhere on that level
but but i was
hurt when i say because you know what it
was my wife and my family and i was like
i'm nothing i'm nothing like i got
nothing and i sat there gained 30 pounds
i was eating burgers and pecan sandies
and
sitting there two in the morning sitting
there just can't even
sleep and then all of a sudden it was
like
my wife kept telling me she said babe
you need a job i was like oh you know
who i am
because i'm trying to keep a little bit
of pride right right
yes trying to keep some sort of like i i
am somebody yeah but they was like
i'm going to take a job as a waiter like
[ __ ] i know
might might
yeah i know i was just thinking when i
my first job in la was a place called it
was at a place called labor ready
and i went in and what it is is you
cause i had nothing listen we were
digging in the couch for quarters
mike we digged in the couch for quarters
so i could get gas i had nothing my wife
was like are you ready
i was like i got to do something labor
ready was this place you could show up
five in the morning you work
with uh drug addicts ex-cons
homeless and they give you a job for
eight hours you get
a check at the end of the day they sent
me to a factory
i was sweeping floors all day for eight
hours and you got i got eight dollars an
hour
and i was so i was hurt like oh my god i
can't believe it i thought i was gonna
die i thought
literally like pic sweeping the floor i
thought i was gonna fall over and die
but you know what mike this was magic
this was magic
magic man i'm sweeping i'm like
whoa i'm actually doing something
about my situation listen to me man let
me tell you
it's i've reframed it because all of a
sudden before i was talking
i was rapping and now i'm doing
because i was talking [ __ ] but doing
[ __ ] makes things change so i started
sweeping and look i got to the end
of the day and i went and got my check
and mike they gave me a check for 64
dollars i could cash it right there
64. they took the taxes out they gave me
48 i took that 20 i took 20 of that 48
gave it to my wife
put 20 in the gas tank i had eight
dollars that i didn't have yesterday
mike
i never was broke again i worked my ass
off
ever since then and i didn't die i
thought i was gonna die cause jack you
said what i'm gonna do i'll be a waiter
[ __ ] that
yup yeah then and then you know what i
found out nobody gave a damn mike no you
think people are looking at you
yeah somebody like yeah
i'm mike tyson i mean yeah hey man
dude that was the test i passed
i passed i worked then i was filing
papers in the veterans administration
then i was doing security i had three
jobs at the same time
mike because i realized people did not
care
and let me tell you something i never
stopped working
to this day i got three jobs now and i'm
still
doing it but it's the same mentality i
can't change that go somewhere else
let's take this to another
because of the success this um man this
rapid success
do you think people have been um you
know especially some people that was on
youtube
um saying the things they've been saying
maybe you think because there's some
jealousy there
oh definitely i mean i'm being honest
people yeah yeah oh man first of all
jealousy is common to man you know what
i mean because
i have you know what i have people
saying i am being paid by white
supremacists
this was crazy oh see terry crews got
his balls felt on
and he let the white boy do it so that
he could get
america's got talent i'm sitting there
like okay
so you orchestrated that oh my god
they they said i orchestrated the whole
thing and that william morris had this
whole plan
this is you when you talk about people
who believe conspiracy theories there's
no end
yeah and so they got it all like worked
out like terry crew see he did that see
and then you can hear them
they go yeah well i i could never do old
spice so cause you know that that's not
me because i'm too much of a
i'm like no look just because nobody's
been calling you
and nobody doing anything because look
at it first of all look at the people
you were in there with you
steve harvey blowing up listen [ __ ]
check it out everything you see
i know when those calls stopped coming
that'd be nice to have all the comments
i had the mike tyson punch i had all
this stuff happening the commercial
hat man man big big um
operations with my commercials with
pepsi cola
then those calls stop coming you start
i'm gonna kind of i'll take the money
and i won't show up
you know oh man i wish i never did that
wow
that's what happened with dmx yeah yeah
you know that's a happy he was gonna be
a movie star
yeah yeah he would show up in the movie
he said six hours late people was like
wait
you gotta understand how movies work
yeah um hey man
what are you doing listen i don't know
about you check this out
i remember when you could be on the
movie set and then you could take a
break lunch time you leave the set
boom next thing that you get how you
never come back
you get hot you don't come back to this
that's why you can't leave the set now
right right they don't let you leave
all the food they bring everything there
yeah they breathe
coming back i remember
no way all my business has been repeat
business though
because they say terry crews gonna work
his ass off oh man that's beautiful to
hear yeah i don't play man i don't play
i show up early
i'm never late i'm always ready i'm
always prepared i know my lines
i know my thing i study because i i took
all because this is the thing man i had
to realize man this is my business
it ain't your business see that's a
problem people this is hard [ __ ] hey man
wait wait if you're working at
a uh whatever burger place people be
like man yeah this your burger place
whatever i show up with him
listen when you realize this is your
place
everything you're doing is you i saw i
said i said listen man no matter where
i'm doing
it's still the terry crews business if i
was flipping burgers i got to make sure
those burgers are well done
you know what i'm saying and they're
done to your specification if i sweep
them floors the floor's got to be clean
because learning that means i can do
anything
at that level you got to learn down
there though
and dude that changed my mindset man
change everything man i was like
i remember when they invite listen when
they invited us to do lip sync battle
it was like well they ain't gonna get no
money we're gonna donate it and the
whole thing and i knew they was just
starting out i said listen man for ll
for for mike for for the people that i
believed in that are doing this show i
got to give you the best
i didn't hold back nothing you don't see
what i mean but you know what happens
you get props all of a sudden people go
my god i love terry crews
i love what he does and all of a sudden
the next job
keeps coming and the next job paying and
see and i that's how i make my money man
and just always always giving people
more than they expect
i learned this a long time ago i had to
fight with it
and i realized that after that one thing
and i was broke
and i realized wait a minute man the
only way to break to break this is
change my attitude i had to change you
know what some of us have to understand
it's just from my experience you know
and i see some
you know brothers out there we have to
understand when we get a job this is
their gig this is not
our show this is their running the show
when i'm running
i used to come in this is my
[ __ ] go told me this is his
[ __ ] show mike
shut the [ __ ] up and do what he tells
you to do he's paying you to do this
[ __ ] man
what the [ __ ] you mean you got this yo
you run this no [ __ ] shut the
[ __ ] up and just read the lines
[ __ ] that's what you're getting
paid for read the [ __ ] lines
listen i don't want to be straight i
want to be real real clear man
mike i love you man um i don't mean
that's the kind of money no
i was listen this is you you know man
first of all
i understand it i understand it and i
understand why people mad at me
i understand i'm not mad at any black
man or any i understand it because
i was just like that yeah but i'm here
to say
i'm here to say that i'm on the other
side
it's like when you see the whole picture
you know i mean you go oh my god it's
like
it's like once you get the aerial view
you go oh damn
you know what i mean i've been in this
view that's been down here
for the longest so it all looks dark but
when you get to ariel you go oh
i see this is not the way i thought it
was
this is not there are certain things
that just don't work
and i ain't mad i ain't mad at dl i
ain't mad at tariq
i i but i do like the fact that we're
having these conversations now
you know we having conversations that we
should have had a long time ago
and the problem is a lot of times is
that white people watching
and that's what gets people mad because
i tried to close the door i tried to be
like hey man look let's talk this out
but the thing is you want to blow me up
you went and made it when i press
conference and open the door so now look
yeah everybody watch it you know i mean
but i love my people man
i love my people i love my community
enough to say something about it
and i'm never leaving and you know what
they they see me dance they see all your
happy negro
he cooning but you know what the thing
is is you can't get rid of my joy
i'm i i know where i could be i'm from
flint michigan
i could be dead i could be in jail i
could be strung out on dope
let me tell you i know i seen it and let
me tell you every day i go back to my
big house
and i drive that big car and i look at
my beautiful wife and i look at them
kids
and make you dance they make you go oh
my god i didn't lose it
dude it makes you happy i will never
ever lose my happiness ever nobody can
take it from me
i'm sorry i'm preaching right now i'm
sorry please brother good talk man
preach man i love y'all man we got deep
we got deep
real oh it's gonna be on the press let's
go i can't wait to see my twitter after
this
you just really have everybody has to
forgive man
and you know what again that word keeps
coming up people like [ __ ] that i ain't
forgiven nothing
i ain't forgiven forgiving but that does
not that's the way out right no but most
most of us are enslaved in that path
yes that's who we are all of us playing
candy straight
our path enslaves us until you forgive
you stay
stuck there's no way you can get out
as if i'm continually mad at somebody
i'm stuck
but you gotta understand that being
feeling mad being mad feels good
it does that's why people want to feel
bad you know
good we got to let it out two things
feel amazing
anger and pity they both feel really
really good
they're like drugs oh my god man all the
pity
feels good it eats you up at the end it
does dude
you know what think about this the most
angry the angriest
most pity pity-filled people those are
the guys that do the mass shootings
yeah that when you reach a level of
anger and pity that that culminates
it usually ends up with somebody
shooting in the crowd and if they don't
have the nerve to do that kind of stuff
they just die miserably
or something right or something right it
eats
can i ask you a question why not you
know i'm looking at all this what do you
think
cause right now legalized gamble is
about to happen in
most sports what do you think i mean
looking at how gambling's affected
boxing
you know you turn around you're like did
they really win i mean what is your take
on gambling
and sports man i think this is something
um
that's been going on since the beginning
of time since roman times since they
have anything they they've been on
[ __ ] road racing yeah
you know i mean that's um that's that's
the core of human beings gambling is
taking risks and stuff like that
and um it's going to happen you know
this is something that's going to happen
because it's profitable as hell but do
you think it could sully
like you know what i mean know why it's
going to be so successful
because teams like nevada are getting
perfect i mean places like the valley
game professional teams now for you
right
right so now that's going to be over now
that's the problem right there now what
are they going to do now
vegas got a professional um team now
what are they going to do i'm just
thinking about them yeah
you know what i mean like all you got to
do is get to one person you don't think
so
please you know what i mean hey baseball
had his scandal the eight man out
scandal yeah
1919 i mean come on black socks it just
makes me worried man like i'm like the
nfl
is so tied in because you know the
owners got a piece of the fanduel they
got a piece of draftkings
yeah sketchy hey man are the players
getting anything
no absolutely none man look at the
phantom call that happened
that put the rams in the super bowl do
you have what kind of idea the crime is
what the crime rate's going to be like
once the team comes there
and vaguely oh come on the raiders vegas
with all these yeah
[Laughter]
right in the middle of the goddamn
freeway yeah oh
that's gonna be nuts homie i don't know
i don't know if i want to be around
yeah i might move wow yeah
i might move that's crazy that's too
much but wait but think about that
what's your what's your take on the call
that put the rams in that
the saints dude that was a straight-up
passage i was just
watching it i was like i was like nobody
threw a flag there
what when all that video i was like
watching i'm like where's the flag hey
man
first of all they got nfl has a huge
stadium coming up in la they have a
vested interest it's the second biggest
market
in america or if not the world
they wanted that lag come on look
listen i wouldn't doubt it but there's a
question
now yeah well with kaepernick still
sitting out
it's all they they know you can collude
they do it
yeah hey man first of all all the
competition is an illusion
it's all owned by the same company yeah
that's the deal like like if they had
another league that was wrong
what do you think about these other
leagues
but they try to do to choke them out
they try anybody's man
this mcmahon what about
i'm glad you made it out of that [ __ ]
not talking funny and [ __ ]
yeah listen i got knocked out on monday
night football man
i hit a guy so hard i knocked myself out
bruh first of all it's the best feeling
in the world yeah i've never been high
in my life but i was like wow
this is amazing and we were playing
indianapolis coast and i looked over
there and they had a
i said what's the you mean what is the
you and they was like dude what are you
talking about
are we in utica and man they was like
punt team i was like i'm on a punt team
but what's a punt what's a pump man oh
yeah
then i started crying wait mike i
started crying because i knew i was
gonna lose my job i said
okay i know i'm on the punt team but i
don't know what a pun is
and they're gonna fire me that was
hilarious
at the time yeah but i look looking back
oh
dude i i'm like man and that back then
you just got dinged yeah
but dude i i don't know what to tell you
even when i played i never reported a
concussion
never i was like i just got dinged dude
you say that
you said i'm hurt cause then i oh okay
well you've got two
see ya you cut too yeah check it out
you're really popular now and you only
showed
all these uh what the [ __ ] you doing
driving alone why are you hanging out by
yourself oh
dude i i don't have a circle i don't
have a tv no
no also nobody knows where i'm going
either gabby can't you see how i just i
just show up you gotta be careful you
see what i mean
no i know but look mike mike there's
only look i
nobody knows where i'm going i don't
make no announcements i'm like oh hey
that's jerry cruz
i'm in ralph's they're like damn it
that's terry crews hey man there's some
dudes
hey man why did you got no security i
looked down and said oh do i need one
are you going by are you doing something
to me right now
i don't know so you i sneak up on their
ass i literally grab
my cookies and i'm in the checkout line
they're like hey
hey you terry you gotta go i always
laugh because mike has a bodyguard
no why i just need them for um crowd
control no just for witnessing what
happens it's good
well wait first if everybody can't stop
somebody fighting me because they're
like
let me say it's for witnesses no if
everybody knew
this is what happened if everybody knew
where i was i would i
yeah like especially if i'm doing a talk
or going somewhere
i have a security like if everybody
terry crews here today
now we got to have police or superiority
because if i'm
out shopping i'm going to play shopping
right i'm on 5th avenue next thing you
know
the whole avenue is crowded people
trying to get we have to lock the door
and i'm by myself yeah so i got to call
somebody
i was the cop got to come and it's just
crazy mike you were one of the most
famous yeah
i can't go anyway first of all there are
people who
there are very few people who have ever
reached your level of fame and
i'm talking biblical status that's like
moses
mike tyson michael jordan
you know gandhi yeah yeah mike tyson
yeah
it's crazy man when you look at now the
the way that um
that they promote they promote in the
way that um technology works now
you can get that famous in one hour 10
minutes just goes
information just goes around the world
so fast but but it's also cotton candy
people forget
that quick too yeah yeah but you
established
it's never like i said when i say that
that level
it's like man dude you you go to remote
parts of africa tonight i said
mike tyson i'm sorry they don't look at
me like uh
white chicks they don't they don't know
my name they'll be like oh they gave me
white chicks
but you that's like mike tyson some of
these places you go real scary and i was
like well
gabby what was that place in algeria god
man it's just um the strongest man rules
not about no copper that the strongest
man ruled and that's toxic
toxic and they got there oh man hey man
look i did
when i did expendables in bulgaria yeah
it's a trip right hey man
i would i was the strongest crew i
wouldn't hang out in the lobby
no it was billionaires hookers
sketchy you i didn't even know i didn't
have people gangsters man no gangsters
people who killed all the money
everybody with black leather jackets
walking around and they were like hey
cruz come here and i'm like oh i
couldn't hear you gotta go and i get in
the elevator man i would go in the
elevator go up because i don't even want
to talk to you you're like come here
come here hey
let me talk to you let me talk to you
anything they could do anything
man you will disappear you will
disappear
that's why i'm telling you talking to me
about that bulgaria you know what i'm
talking about dude we
you there was people that was there one
day and wasn't near the net
and you like man just be nice to people
it was like 15 tony sopranos all sitting
down
in the lobby god
danger today man we got a good in
america yeah i mean we do we do
you go to other countries man crazy it's
crazy when they
when they go to our jail over here it's
like the [ __ ] holiday inn
yeah our prisons here like the
hallelujah oh yeah yeah
oh they like man y'all got a nice prison
love it
i love it i don't want to leave it they
don't want to come out stay
in there okay how did you guys meet
wow where did we how did we meet you
know what we again
we all i always remember remember we did
remember we did that stuff with the
windings too
yes we did the one yeah yeah we did we
did a
and it was a song and that was one of
the first times i actually see because i
met mike but mike didn't remember me i
had high top fade and
mike was in his glory you know what i
mean i was waving from this thing like
i'm at prince the same night yeah and it
was wild cause
it was prince you prince the queen
latifah
wesley snipes was all down there i mean
this was at the height man this was
crazy
and i was just i remember walking around
my high top fade i had on overalls and i
was like oh my god
first rookie year wow so then later play
eric dickson
yeah i know i play after him after him
it was back when uh
you know i played with daryl henley all
them cats and he got caught up with
drugs and
40 years time big time 49 years
in all the papers and then i remember
that you remember that yeah it's crazy
listen so that that it's funny because
now that i've i've reached a level of
fame which is crazy i remember meeting
prince after i started doing everybody
hates chris and i was actually invited
to his house
it was after golden globes and i
couldn't believe it he was like i enjoy
your show and i was like oh my god
prince prince and see and then when you
come up to mike and mike knows you and
mike says hey
hey t come here and are you going man
look hey man i'm getting i'm actually
getting emotional right now because
no i just remember looking out my window
in flint and just wanting to be
something
like can i just do something like
i got to get out of here oh man
you know what i mean like i used to
watch people i said man can i just
i don't want to get trapped here because
that was the point it was
like crazy listen how um you visualize
that [ __ ] and
it finds you and it takes you and you're
like whoa where am i going where am i
going yeah what the [ __ ] what happened
how did i get here yes
how come all these people you know but
you forget you put in the work
i said and the work is magic it's it's
that's how i feel all the work is magic
to have people that you admire and love
and they're like man
jerry come here you like like you know
me listen you know who came up and i'm
gonna tell you man henry winkler came up
to me at the golden globe
i can't wait to work with you one day
dude come on man that's awesome that's
divine
hey man like i said dude you get weepy
you get like
no this is people these are people i
watch as a kid
and i watch probably every episode of
happy days four or five times in a row
four or five every day you just sit
there and you're like my god he knows me
hey man it's just crazy being at those
like we were talking about earlier those
award shows and all those celebrities
and
just having to pinch yourself it's
unreal but then you also
also see this is the thing that's
tripping me out especially now
is that you start to see this all these
people ain't good people
you know they want to see you do good
they shine oh dude
i mean when i look at when i look at
even with cosby
i mean i looked up to him man and i was
like damn it
i mean i grew up on fat albert grew up
on a little bill grew up on all this
stuff man i'm going man
i watched the college be sure that was
my example of what a
black father would look like man and i
was like come on man
and then you start to realize listen man
i don't care about the image no more
i don't care now you got to be good
people
like before it was good enough it was
good enough for me that you was a great
person a good image of
but now i want to see that as a real
person you know what i mean
i don't want to see no fakeness i don't
want to see no fakeness i don't i'm not
around fake people
i don't want to be fake i'm not fake
because i used to be
i used to be two people they used to be
faking like hey
i'm good and then go home and be another
person i realize like somebody told me
one time
they said hey man is it hard to keep up
your image i was like man
you can't have an image dude you just
got to be you you just got to be you
might one thing i love about you right
now you are you
dog like you see what you see is what
you get
that's what i love and when i look at
but you could see other things where
you're like man some dude is playing
he's gaming everybody
and i've seen that and you hear people
and when they really talking
it's like it's you know it's like it's
like having somebody go ah yeah i love
everybody and then you hear them say
yeah that [ __ ]
you go whoa whoa what was that listen if
you're a friend of everybody you're
enemy to yourself
yes yes
so i'm man i'm glad we got real i needed
this this is therapy
this is you know what first of all this
is all therapy this is all real therapy
talking through this stuff
yeah sorting it out asking questions hey
man people can get mad at me for any
comment
but we gonna talk about it yeah if
everybody stops talking about it because
they're too scared to get a tweet
i don't care we're [ __ ] man we ask we
gotta talk about it if we don't ask
questions
we finish communicate just [ __ ] get
it out there
why not yeah and that's the only way we
can start sorting stuff out man
i appreciate that's why i i appreciate
this mike thank you for coming
so happy you came though yeah man you
got your show
brooklyn nine-nine yeah what else you
got going on i'm hosting
uh america's got time america's got
talent the champions i i have a song
yeah yeah and uh simon heidi mel howie
the whole time
i'm doing that there's people out here
you know this may be people say you
don't hear books and you do need to get
the job but there's people here that say
[ __ ] you that's so awesome like usually
we're impressed with that hey man you
know how hard it is for a brother to get
some jobs
first of all when you you're not
haunting that listen
i have i have i don't care how much
dancing you doing to get some job and to
be qualified to have the job
i don't you can't do that too much dance
enough dancing
like i just think that too you ain't
doing enough dancing but i've been
dancing for black people yeah see that
was thing i danced for black people
first
and let me tell you this to sit in front
to stand in front of 30 to 40 million
people
every week and wait and they and the
problem is they love you
and and people get mad when they like
you they're like
how do they like you and i'm like man i
am just me and i got two shows on nbc
brah
it you don't get bigger than nbc i've
got
hundreds hundreds of hours of television
everybody hates chris
uh brooklyn nine-nine white [ __ ]
all the movies i've done the whole
career man it just gets bigger and
better
and dude i i am forever grateful
for ever grateful like i said you can't
steal my joy man that damn awesome
brother that dance that happened in
flint
back in the day you know what i'm
awesome no problem
it's so powerful dude [ __ ] well you'll
have to come back man because i feel
like i could talk to you for hours i
know this is good
i think it just stayed here man but we
all been through it that's
in my situation i always carry the
weight of a fool by myself but even
though other people contribute you know
what i mean
i always carry the weight but even
though you say you let these people
steal your [ __ ] happiness
you can't let them do that no never see
oh
okay you know there's nothing else to
say to that i'm saying i'm literally
like
that that right you killed people still
yeah
so easy to happen just to get in the
tweet somebody says hey you [ __ ]
dance and buckle [ __ ]
that could dance somebody's happiness up
they don't know how to take it they
can't internalize it and [ __ ] themselves
up but you know i i know how to take it
though
i've been very very patient because i i
understand
a lot of you have to because they're
painful it's painful but they're mad
they you know what again it's just that
it's painful stuff
see i know that because i've said nasty
things to people and people said nasty
and i thought that's the way life should
be
and then when i found out about
forgiveness and happiness and accepting
who you are
you know i mean forgiving yourself i
learned all that [ __ ] and i thought that
was all [ __ ] at first
cliche you learned to love yourself and
you said you know what you said i'm
sorry i said those things you found out
how
nasty those things were you know
and it's never ended like that stuff
gets done get started it's like a toilet
it's about growing up
you know it's hard to grow up people
gotta keep staying drama
unless they're not irrelevant if they're
not in drama they're not relevant
gotta be drama it can't be anything
intellectual can't be anything soulful
gotta be drama without drama and nothing
they don't exist i feel so blessed terry
i get to hear
mike talk like this all the time dude
it's crazy
crazy man i'm about to go out here and
do something special right now yeah
hell yeah brother i'm gonna hand out
some flowers to people right now
hell yeah you know i've got to tell you
inspired
it's life yeah good man this is the
toughest man in the world yeah
wait you are talking to thee nah but
listen man
i know how hard it is to be out there to
be blackman the big man the pre
you know the queen's the target the
target the big buck kind of guy out
there
and to get a job man you know because
they're afraid of you you know you got
the stereotype on you yeah
great episode mikey thank you terry
you're the man there's about everything
about
this is beautiful until next time
everybody i'm evan britton
that's mike tyson terry crews awesome
thank you terry and
we'll see you guys next time peace